[Music]
overall would i say that elon musk
is good for the environment
on balance i just don't know
i have no idea what he has done
to popularize the electric car you can't
take that away from him
that's massive at the same time you
can't ignore the fact that elon musk has
done a lot to make
clean energy sexy and exciting
but on the other side it is very clear
that he's making
sketchy and difficult trade-offs when it
comes to the recent investments that he
has made
i love the idea that so many more people
can access space you hate the idea that
so many more people can access space
he's also fighting for carbon capture
and storage he's also building this
renewable energy infrastructure
that's always the problem with musk is
balancing out the good
and the not so good because of all these
different things that he does
if we're talking about his biggest
contribution to
the environment the disruption of the
auto industry and the popularization
of the electric car has to be has to be
the number one
tailpipe emissions represent a large
part of the carbon emissions that are
warming the earth faster than we needed
to be warming
so the fact that he has made the
electric car
viable and popular means a lot
we've had electric cars before tesla and
they were never popular they were always
little bugs
that you'd see pottering around the
street and they went 100 miles
and it was it was undesirable object
something that doesn't look good isn't
fast it doesn't have high performance
it has low range we wanted to break the
mould of all of that
high acceleration incredible handling
tons of capability
lots of room and better than any
gasoline car that's what we sought to
achieve
that has had a profound shift on how
people think about the space
and it's impossible to discount at what
cost is another question
if you look at some of the suppliers
that tesla uses for the
materials needed for its batteries you
know nickel and cobalt
and the mining operations there there
are massive environmental concerns you
know elon musk has addressed them
himself saying
he will give a huge contract to whatever
miner can
can mine nickel more sustainably or in a
more environmentally friendly way
the vehicles themselves are very large
they they require all of those exotic
materials in the battery packs and so
forth
plus they're not all that efficient i
mean the typical tesla s could be
2 200 kilos that's a lot of car
that means that most of the battery is
being spent moving the battery is an
electrified traditional muscle car
that's not a great deal of progress for
me
look there's a good argument to be made
that everyone should be driving less
cars
full stop and really if you wanted to
change the environmental structure of
america lobbying for high-speed rail
would be a
pretty good way to start that not
building high-end electric cars for
rich californians it may begin with a
fancy sports car but that's not where
the story ends
these new technologies they always start
off expensive
but where we win where we really move
the needle
is by making it something accessible and
desirable
for everyday people and that's what elon
musk
has done for the world he started right
at the top of the market
and then he rode the technology down
into the mainstream and he said look
all that technology all that style now
you can get it too
and i've managed to get the price down
to 35 40 000
he opens the door to people's
imagination of what it'll be like
to have a completely fossil fuel free
society it'll be
better than what we have today this is a
future you can
feel really excited and optimistic about
i think it really matters
that's why tesla's valued at what it's
valued it's not worth more than toyota
because it sells more cars than toyota
it's worth more than toyota
because investors have determined in
their heads that
he is going to revolutionize the world
and they think you know he's going to
let us keep doing what we want to do all
the time we don't need to worry about it
because elon's got it
that's a really compelling idea
technology will save us
it will arrive in the future and make
our problems go away but critics would
argue that
it's not really realistic just getting
there
painlessly we have to really think very
hard about how we want to live our lives
and and really kind of rain back on
that high consumption lifestyle all the
evidence points to this
whether that means flying less eating
less meat
driving your personal car less you name
it individuals will need to change their
behavior
there's not just some magic silver
bullet that will arrive
and make all these problems disappear
so in january elon musk announced the x
prize for for carbon capture they're
going to offer 100 million dollars to
whoever wins this and the goal is to try
to
pull carbon out of the atmosphere
[Music]
the technology that exists right now is
expensive
no one has cracked the code to
developing
carbon capture technology that works at
scale at a price
where it would be feasible to really
play a big part in the fight against
climate change
so the prize says we'll select 15 teams
each of the 15 teams gets a million
dollars to try and figure something out
and then at the end of the process in
five years the winner gets 50 million
there's runners-up etc it's the largest
private
incentivized competition ever launched
and the level of interest is very high
and it has created a whole new buzz in
the
climate industry frankly with the goal
that by
2050 we have to be able to remove 10
gigatonne
of co2 from the atmosphere and nothing
indicated that the industry will be able
to achieve that without a nudge and
the xprize carbon competition is that
nudge all we want to see
is show us how you do it and we'll show
you the money
but it is also a way of taking away
part of the responsibility from
ourselves knowing that there is money
pumped into large-scale technologies
that potentially
will save us from disaster
we have to cut emissions and all of
these you know big picture sort of
sci-fi
initiatives they get a lot of blow back
from the
climate science community some people
have even told me
what we're doing is slowing down
progress of those industries
to make it change but i always say when
your house is on fire you can just sit
there and watch it burn down with the
hopes that someone will come out and put
out the fires we've been
waiting for that to happen for too long
and if we don't make this move now it
will be too late
we need to consume less first and
foremost that's absolutely
a truth but climate change is too
overwhelming of a problem
we have to give average everyday people
a sense of the possible
it's frightening and people want to
believe
that there is a techno king as he has
deemed himself savior that's going to
come in
and keep us all from you know suffering
as we will under global warming
what's really important for people to
understand is that humans are going to
still need to move themselves and their
products
around through technology and so we need
electricity
we're in vertical climb on co2 levels
um and we need to do everything we
possibly can
to accelerate the transition to
sustainable energy
elon musk's greatest contribution is in
showing what's possible
to generate that electricity without
fossil fuels
tesla also owned solarcity which is one
of the
biggest residential solar panel owners
in the u.s and tesla also has a sizable
battery business of course
and energy storage is the main
bottleneck in making the transition
to a fully renewable energy system
if we're going to switch to renewables
we need a way to use wind and solar
power when the sun is not shining
or the wind is not blowing and to do
that you need some way to store that
energy
some of the current projects are using
basically car batteries
at a very large scale we are literally
shutting down dirty old fossil fuel
power plants
and replacing them with solar energy
paired with energy storage
so the moss landing project in
california is one of the most
picturesque examples energy storage is
also modular and it can fit into small
nooks and crannies of our built
environment so it can fit behind the
meter
at customer sites whether that's a
hospital or a home or a school
and locating energy at the point where
people use it
helps us get to that clean energy future
we want to get to
it consists of a really appealing solar
roof
um then combined that with with storage
and with electric cars so it's a three
it's an obvious three-part solution
yeah three-part solution this is an
interesting vision
have you ever looked at it from my own
house you know um i've got an electric
car
i'm thinking you know put my panels up
on the roof in an ideal world i would
have
domestic battery storage so that when
the sun wasn't shining i could charge my
car
from my own electricity over time
there's been a real trend especially in
the american
west of making that happen through
putting batteries
inside people's homes and those
batteries when added together
already today actually outshine what
we're doing at the utility scale level
we have approximately 50
000 batteries that are connected to our
energy grid here in california
they total somewhere around a gigawatt
of energy
capacity so the market and the business
community has been around for a very
long time
what i think elon musk did is he
communicated directly to the masses in
ways that other businesses
hadn't yet been able to do he's worked
this groove between the products we
desire like electric cars
but on the other hand you know the
vision the you know we can solve big
problems
kind of idea and he is one of the only
just about the only person who's
managing to work that groove right now
i believe in a renewable energy future i
believe that humanity
must become a multi-planetary space
bearing civilization
those seem like exciting goals don't
they
it's like he's a k-pop band it's it's
crazy and he's able to
use that in many ways you know he can
move markets with a single tweet
whether it's something he says about
tesla whether it's something he says
about bitcoin whether it's something he
says about dogecoin
elon musk is effectively the governor of
the central bank of
crypto you know his whims are exactly
the sorts of announcements that you need
to be looking at to determine
what bitcoin is going to do next
which is kind of fine if you think you
have a good sense of what elon musk is
going to do next but i'm not convinced
that anyone
does to be honest in early february
tesla announced that it would invest
1.5 billion dollars into bitcoin that's
about
11 of the company's cash
yet three months later he reversed
course
and in a single tweet he said we're not
going to buy any more bitcoin we're not
going to sell bitcoin either because
we decided that this is bad for the
climate i've decided it's bad for
climate which of course
everybody already knew with 70 of global
bitcoin production being positioned
in china where the grid is very much
relying on doherty coal
the production of bitcoins in itself
produces as much co2 as a small country
and compare it for example to visa each
bitcoin transaction uses the same amount
of power as 436
000 visa transactions so it's hardly
environmentally friendly
since this announcement in february the
tesla was loading up on bitcoin the
shares have fallen
about 20 and in part that's because
for a lot of investors that i speak to
this bitcoin
moment was a bridge too far ultimately
when you're buying 1.5 billion dollars
worth of bitcoin
you're not really concerned with the
environmental footprint that goes with
it
because the numbers are just so stark
you're much more
looking at profit you know people
suspect maybe that's what he's in it for
is he just talking prices up and down
is this just one big market manipulation
on the other hand of course you can
imagine him thinking well this is
this is part of the long term future i'm
building more efficient
scalable fast working and decentralized
transactions
the idea that money could simply be
turned into bits on computers
and not anybody's computer not not some
central bank's computer
but our computers that it's a completely
decentralized thing that's a bit of
shared code between
anybody who wants to use it is an
incredibly
revolutionary and liberating idea for
someone like mask
so it might just be about you know
speculation and making
a lot of money but it could also be an
indication that that is how he sees
the world moving and not just this world
you know he really does believe
that humans will be on mars and when
they get there they certainly won't be
taking their
earthbound currencies with them they
won't be taking any of the institutions
with them
three two one
ignition we have liftoff
i think it's important for the long term
preservation and and ultimately
expansion and extension of this the
scope and scale of consciousness
and the long-term uh probability of
survival of
humanity and life as we know we must
become a multi-planet species one of the
most
curious things about elon musk's vision
for
the future is that he really believes
humans will
come to colonize space it may be that he
is more interested in the sustainability
of humankind than
the sustainability of the earth which is
why he's creating this lifeboat but i
think an easier way to sustain human
life is to sustain the planet
we are on executing plan b
will compromise plan a because already
the footprint
is not going to be environmentally
friendly
if you look at for example the rockets
how great is that
for the actually quite fragile coastal
regions where these rockets take off
from and
not infrequently explode the challenge
is that
rockets burn a lot of fuel emitting co2
and lots of other things
high into the atmosphere and that's a
problem
when you see these things take off you
often see a gray or a white
plume in the lower atmosphere that's
because it collects
water typically so it's it's wider but
then there's this middle region where
it's fairly dry
and there's not a lot of oxygen of
course up high and then that's where you
probably get a lot of unburned things
or you deal with the formation of [ __ ]
things which we call black carbon
the soot particles can collect and
accumulate in the stratosphere and there
are a lot of questions about
you know as they absorb the sunlight
then to what extent do they contribute
to
warming this minor player this one or
two percent
is a hundred thousand to a million times
more absorptive to solar energy
than the carbon dioxide itself
and we can't tell you what the impact is
they're only beginning to do those
studies partly because we don't launch
that many rockets you know
every year there's a lot and they're
growing fast but ultimately compared to
a lot of other sectors the sector
is relatively small in terms of actual
carbon emissions
but what we're living through is a is
the opening of a space and it's very
hard to
exaggerate the impact of spacex in
creating what we think of today is the
commercial space
industry lower cost means more launches
between 2010 and 2019 there were on
average
about 260 satellites launched a year
well on average over the next decade
euroconsult expects us to see about 1250
satellites launched a year people
haven't really thought about the impact
of
all of these rocket launches to get the
satellites
up into into orbit or indeed about the
re-entry of the dead satellites as they
come to the end of their life
they fall back into the earth's
atmosphere and burn up
you know this isn't too dissimilar from
the way we've treated our own planet you
know let's do something that's
convenient and then we'll think about
cleaning it up later
that kind of premise is the idea that's
actually driven a lot of natural
destruction and a lot of environmental
degradation
throughout history uh
the last thing i want to see is for
people to be scared
that environmental analysis of rockets
is going to somehow shut down commercial
rocketry i mean that
has its own negative effects when you
look at space
technology i think people just think we
have so much
problem here on earth why are we even
doing anything in space
what they forget is so many technologies
around us
is because of the fact that we wanted to
explore space
what we've accomplished as humans in my
lifetime
is unbelievable i've been at cape
canaveral
watching a space shuttle take off this
is hope
and this is beauty and our job here
isn't to stop
things from happening our job is to make
it better
there's a lot we don't know but also
this new space
rush that we have now is hugely
beneficial to us in terms of tracking
the impact on the climate of carbon
emissions of deforestation
of lots of things that are going on on
the planet that we had no idea were
happening before
so this is exactly the type of issue
that is going to
drive a wedge you know between masks
fans and enemies if you like
everyone he certainly if nothing else
has faith in innovation he embodies the
silicon valley mindset
that we can disrupt our way to a better
future
for them it's a silver bullet towards
everything is finding a technology
solution with in itself
at the end is only part of it with new
technology there's always a kind of
love-hate relationship you can't escape
the fact that
musk is a very divisive character but if
you don't have creative destruction you
never move forward
there's a lot of problems in the world
but if we don't have things that
inspire us what's the point of living he
doesn't
just invent things for the sake of
disruption it has a purpose and this
purpose
has been to create a more sustainable
lifespan for humanity
if you're talking about taking emissions
to nearly zero you need
wealthy billionaires and millionaires to
splurge on fancy electric vehicles
just like you need federal governments
to spend on
better infrastructure for public
transportation it's all useful and i
think
that probably outweighs some of his more
questionable environmental choices at
least for now